hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now we
have officially got our Cyclops and the
reason that we built the Cyclops is so
that we could go down farther than we've
ever gone before and explore some of the
new biomes that are completely buried
beneath the black abyss that is the
ocean but before we do that I obviously
got to deal with the naming of our new
Cyclops and three people help me out
with this one
GI joystick who said boaty mcboatface
which if you didn't know there was a
boat that was supposed to be named boaty
mcboatface but it wasn't named that so
it was actually one of the little
lifeboats on the boat guy named that but
that's a big story that no one cares
about so thank you so much but Raimondo
daniel said the SS spoopy and i kind of
wanted in the name of the SS spooby
poopy but the winner in my opinion is n
em Heath oh three one who said to name
it the note boat which in my opinion is
like it just made me laugh a lot because
pretty much the entire ocean - screaming
nope at the top of my lungs so I don't
know what we're gonna see down in these
new biomes we're going down into the
lost river and then we're gonna revisit
the inactive lava zone if we have time
and it's going to be a delightful
experience but thank you guys so much
and I've got the materials necessary
already to build the pressure
compensator now if you want to actually
build the pressure compensator you have
to build a brand new fabricator on your
Cyclops so you have you can't just use
the one in your base you have to use one
that's custom built right here that I
put there but first we're gonna name
this one the nope boat because in
addition to USS [ __ ] the ocean which i
think is an app name but this one is
just oh hello
this one is just too much for me so
we're gonna new color this there we go
base color bright pink stripe color
probably a nice green going through
there maybe a bit darker darker green
that looks pretty good stripe - we're
gonna have
Oh take it of RAD I'm thinking red looks
pretty good I thinking red and then the
name could be its own color that's
awesome
can I only have that pink too nah that
wouldn't stand out yellow that's gonna
stand out
I bet this thing looks real good I gotta
I gotta go outside to actually see
what's going on here
hello oh my god oh it's beautiful
yeah the no boat I love it it's perfect
that is so cool okay anyway enough
geeking out about that so now we need to
build the pressure compensators and I
actually got all the materials necessary
and there's a custom option called
submarine down here for the Cyclops
pressure compensator and you like the
other thing you can get up to four of
them so I'm just gonna go ahead and make
four it's gonna consume some power right
it I gotta watch the power level that we
use in here because there's no current
method on the Cyclops that I know of to
make it recharge as it goes along
I could try to put solar panels on the
roof but I don't know if that would help
so we're gonna take out the power
efficiency module which would be nice
but that's not why we're here we're here
to go into the desk how deep is how deep
is your love what mattered only what I
can't do for what god damnit why did I
get the materials for four then that's
stupid
we only 900 that doesn't make any
goddamn sense how can I go farther what
what okay I guess you can only have one
upgrade at a time well that sucks but
anyway this should still be enough to
get us down to the Lost River I don't
know if it's enough to get us down into
the inactive lava zone again because
that requires a whole whole hell of a
lot but we'll get to that in just a
second because we need to go to the Lost
River and if I'm not mistaken we need to
breach cuz I need to know where I'm
oriented des huh oh geez okay so where
in the heck what
what is that whoa I got a camera I don't
need to breach
oh no wait this is just a side careful
so I can see where I'm backing up oh
that's awesome that's awfully convenient
but not why I'm here
okay so we need to breach again I just
need to see where the goddamn ship is
where's the goddamn ship is it goddamn
behind me god damn big-ass Cyclops there
it is okay so it's over there man that
life buoy drifted quite a ways okay I
gotta I gotta watch where that going or
else I'm gonna lose it forever but
either way dive dive dive how do I dive
okay I need to turn on the lights before
I do any of this
yeah oh I got it where are they on there
they go yeah they're on okay there we go
on alright let's do this god I can't see
a goddamn thing
oh well that's not why we do this we go
and do god it is just whoa roof okay
oh this spooky but just wait till we get
did what is that whoa uh-oh oh oh oh god
oh god damn it it just wasn't loading in
I was wondering why I was wade rker than
it should have been holy [ __ ] I can't
see a goddamn thing oh just lucky
god dammit Jesus that scared the piss
out of me why it's just a wall why is
there a wall here oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it's a
big guy oh don't take me oh don't take
me I just got my Cyclops oh the no boat
isn't open out looking out here bruh
full speed okay but I know where I am
now that is definitely what I was
talking about and I'm gonna come there
eventually
I might coming in the back way because
there's less Glassons hello hi oh jeez
Wood jeez okay we're fine we're fine
everything's fine everything's fine but
I know where I am now so if i skirt
along this mushroom force to the south
which i believe is where i'm going now
I believe where I'm going now and if I
follow this I should be able to get
exactly where I'm gonna be and now I can
actually see things because I'm kind of
parallel to the ocean floor instead of
being way too far above it acting like
I'm all better than everything will oh
okay we're getting close I think this is
definitely it coming up right on it here
yeah that looks like a crevasse if I
ever saw one
okay so this should be it so if I start
dropping here this should get me woo oh
god I thought that was a thing this is a
mountainside man this is it's making me
paranoid but yeah this is this is the
crevasse this is indeed the crevasse and
if I go down here yep visit I can see
the elements of the blood kelp zone okay
yep the others it okay so this should be
the entrance to the Lost River somewhere
down here
I gotta find what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna Scout first I got a scout in my my
seamoth wow it is dark and creepy in
this place Oh what is that is that my
seamoth all blowed up because it got
damaged probably when I rammed into my
second wow why captain why okay it's
something else barely okay so oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] I know what I can't do this oh god
what the [ __ ] whatever why I couldn't
get enough
Oh got it damn it I've got a million
problems but I'm not turning back
you ain't gonna stop me just come from
God huh I don't care who starts singing
in my ear
god dammit I may have to cheat myself
some food no wait I got food yeah I got
food oh gods do God ah [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] what was it uh filtered yeah
that was it okay get a get a get a get a
point not not that oh Jesus criminy
Christmas ha ha
okay I see it ah there's just another
crevasse down right below this okay I
got it
whose hard is legitimately difficult but
there should be directly below me right
here whoo right here yeah this is okay
this is it this is it found it found it
found it found it found it I don't know
if this is the river but there's at
least another way down which is where
I'm supposed to be going
oh yeah we're killing it on the depth
now holy [ __ ]
whoo we're going down whoo we're going
down okay
Oh whoa what the [ __ ] this just appeared
out of goddamn nowhere oh [ __ ] oh oh
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I think is it I think I entered
a different biome and that's why the
lighting changed holy tits oh my god oh
wow oh wow okay
whoa what does happen my orientation was
going all over the place
I'm getting batted around ooh we're
going deeper but only slightly deeper
this definitely wasn't here before at
least if it was I never found it oh wow
getting cavernous here this is kind of
like when I first entered the inactive
lava zone and I saw like the scale of it
all
like this is scale of it the fact that
it's all underground too like that
throws me oh wow oh geez I want to get
out and explore but it doesn't seem like
I'm quite there yet
oh man Wow
whoa god damn it what the [ __ ] man holy
[ __ ] that thing is [ __ ] huge I'm
gonna see it I'm gonna be scared oh my
god oh my god how did I miss that
he they're not loading holy [ __ ] look at
this thing look at this thing what the
[ __ ] holy crap
oh it's awesome it's so cool sorry
that's awesome oh my I don't want to go
in its mouth cuz I know well then [ __ ]
it up oh jeez oh jeez oh jeez oh jeez oh
jeez ah gee Scoob
oh gee Scoob oh I'm getting outta here
whoa oh it's terrifying
just to thought that something this big
could possibly exist in this world
I mean it's graveyard yeah okay ha
that's just the entrance of it let's see
if there's more here that might be the
only thing in here I have no idea you
know frankly part of me wants it to be
the only thing but this has a way that
just popped up out of nowhere holy [ __ ]
oh man Wow Wow okay moving along I think
we've we can officially say that we
found the Lost River Oh what is this why
does it take me down a narrow tunnel is
that blocked off is it blocked off that
is blocked off isn't it
holy [ __ ] why how and why maybe this is
the side of the UH
because we're down at the same depth I
bet this is just a wall separating the
inactive lava zone for now probably a
temporary thing and just like not
exactly permanent fixture of it they
probably haven't fixed up too much of
this stuff but still god damn damn
where'd he go this it's gonna pop up and
scare me again ah sorry I'm just a
little excited it's really cool well I'm
gonna go over here I'm gonna see if
there's anything else in some nook and
cranny in here somewhere
maybe there's an even bigger scholar
hopefully a smaller skull but I don't
think it's gonna be I think it's kind of
just this layer like where this thing
died and maybe like I don't entirely
understand like the scope of this thing
and how old this corpse is it doesn't
seem like there's a whole lot here
and the more I go around the more it
seems like there was just one entrance
and it just wasn't loaded up and it
looked like there was a lot of different
entrances but let me go out one more
time uh just scan around the environment
because yeah that is Wow that is massive
Jesus it is so cool okay so I might have
come from over there but I don't think
so and I think that's just a way man
I've no idea it's easy to get lost down
here but I'm gonna try to go this way
because it's think it's a little bit
different from where I came from which
might have been over there but if this
is I will go back we'll see oh man
that's really cool cam going up which is
a good sign I suppose I guess oh man
okay there we go that's it well that's
part of the same area but I don't recall
going in there unless there's like a
side entrance there's like two entrances
to it and they both go one way or
another
which i think might be what happened
there yeah I think when I went in I went
to the right and when it came out I came
out on the left side so I'm just gonna
assume that I made a circle and I
circled back to where I was before
because holy crap yeah I definitely went
in the right side there okay that's okay
don't freaking me out for a little bit
there everything's good we're still
alive if he's fun and happy and free oh
oh what is that whoa what are you whoa
what are you what are you what are you
what are you you were a thing Wow Oh
what are you oh my god what is that oh
there's fragments down there and I want
them I'm gonna come say hi to you I
don't care if you kill me I care very
much oh god how do I god dammit why am I
always such an appealing to get back
into my goddamn food
[ __ ] that guy I want him I want the
fragments I'm gonna get him and I'm
gonna get him I need a first aid kit
where the [ __ ] ah [ __ ] never mind
bailing oh God look ed what back I'm
stuck I'm stuck I'm [ __ ] stuck oh god
damn it
never mind I'm done okay I'm not getting
on fragments be damned what the [ __ ] was
that all about so anyway I'm all done
with this episode I am sorry for Colton
I know I am sorry for having to cheat
but I'm only gonna cheat in dire
circumstances where the alternative is
going all the way back to the base and
just to get some food because that seems
illogical so I won't be getting any more
building materials from it so don't
worry about that it's just gonna be to
get in and out of here so next time
we're gonna explore the inactive lava
zone again because there might be a new
friend in there but we'll see
we don't know I've heard rumors but we
don't know so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video oh my oh god
oh that's bad
very big Oh sixes jar of mayo